und sie
stücke mit davonkommen
[Musik]
nico gärtner und mike wittner
auszusuchen das einfache leben mit ihren
kindern wandern sie aus nach costa rica
beatrice und marcel buchholzer aus dem
kanton solothurn wurden noch einmal
durchstarten auf kreta eröffnen sie eine
bar
von clarus nach australien familie
landolt möchte mit den ureinwohnern
zusammenarbeiten und betreibt ein ferien
resort in down under
[Musik]
auf kreta sucht marcel buchholz sei die
katze caché sie ist seit mehreren tagen
verschwunden
ehefrau tricks macht das gästezimmer
parat sie erwartet besuch aus der
schweiz ihre gedanken sind aber bei kc
tasche sie prüft ob ich singe
schlimmste aber heute morgen
kontakt
womit mit dem
48 sie zwischen vier und sechs
und die hat
was ich anziehe oder warum ausgegangen
ist
ich hoffe
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
stürzte sich masse buchholzer mit
vollgas in die renovierung der bar
der haussegen hing schief durch den
stress in der bar
in costa rica mussten mike wittner und
nicole gerstner den hausmeister und
seine familie vor die tür setzen sie
wollen die unterkunft von carla und
carmelo zu einem ferienhaus umbauen
in australien verhandelten schul und
miriam dold noch einmal mit dem
verkäufer von friday krieg
jetzt brauchen landolf so schnell wie
möglich das geld sie haben banker
eingeladen und stellen ihr neues konzept
vor
[Musik]
was ist mit katze geschehen tricks hofft
dass eine tierpsychologin aus der
schweiz helfen kann
wie verträgt
sich
schwer mit
der gage gräbt und porsche sind sehr
sehr traurig dass sie fertig und
sie
bestand gestiegen
und das mögen sie nicht verboten ist
er endlich klartext mit einander reden
fakten auf den tisch
gestellt die den monitor
dargestellt werden ausstellung gehören
das ist richtig und
sie für mich sie mir ganz ganz ganz fest
[Musik]
trotz stress marcel sollte seine tricks
nicht vergessen
[Musik]
auf heideck weg hoffen landes die
rettende idee gefunden zu haben für das
ferienressort müssen sie verkäufer bill
noch 1,9 millionen franken bezahlen
jetzt präsentieren sie bankern aus coffs
harbour ihr neues konzept zusätzlich zum
ferien resort wollen sie landwirtschaft
betreiben die banken sollen als
investoren in das projekt einsteigen mit
diesem geld könnte die familie dann auch
das resort bezahlen eine stunde haben
sie verhandelt
die banker nehmen das konzept mit und
prüfen es es sind begeistert von dem
mann machen obwohl investiert erwarte
zwar noch keine medizin sein und wann es
zehn cent also sollte befriedigt sehen
sie die servicequalität
und das klingt dann ganz versöhnlich
geld
ist mir nach wurde das ist einfach nur
bitter da was wirklich spannend da ich
das lustig man eigentlich sofort ein
christ wir sind die beste option oder
jäger hat erfordert gelege schafften mit
zudem dies
mit mir mit kinderwagen der hose und das
business support post hat mit uns
gemacht hat er jahrelang
landes müssen käufer bild seit monaten
vertrösten bereits zwei mal standen sie
mit banken kurz vor dem abschluss aber
diese haben shop nicht als sicherheit
akzeptiert und die zinsen für den kredit
waren jeweils zu hoch mit der neuen idee
könnten sie doch noch investoren finden
von alldem merken die gäste nichts das
wären resort läuft unter miriams führung
immer besser
maria hat mittlerweile zwei putzfrauen
sie helfen bei der reinigung der neuen
ferienhäuser
ich hoffe dass im team und das lohnte
aber wir sind natürlich viele filme
bücher oder müssen taxiert das vokal
duisburg und du darfst wenn man dann im
team staffel effizienteres kunze
die gäste geben sich die klinke in die
hand
jetzt müsste nur noch die bank ja sagen
zum ferien resort und zur landwirtschaft
[Musik]
29 grad warmes wasser das ganze jahr
über und wellen die die welt bedeuten
die neue heimat von nicole gerstner und
ihrer familie seit fünf monaten lebt sie
im ferienort santa teresa in ihrem leben
ist der alltag wieder eingekehrt wie
schon in thun kümmert sie sich um
haushalt und kinder und sie macht yoga
in einem ferienressort hat sich nicole
zu einem kurs angemeldet
[Musik]
nicole findet langsam die ruhe die sie
sich von costa rica versprochen hat
auf ihrem grundstück organisiert mike
wittner den bau des ersten ferienhauses
bis vor zwei monaten hat hier der
ehemalige hausmeister carmelo mit seiner
familie gewohnt unter aufsicht von
architekt gar dies soll jetzt ein
stilvolles gästehaus entstehen
morgen kommt es schwanger doch das sind
die fenster schon einzubauen ja nur den
rahmen nur die trauben hier wird es
einen run geben
ringsherum wenn er montiert ist kann man
die abschlüsse machen
demontiert also nicht das eigentliche
fenster gut einfach nur zuschauen ist
für mike ungewohnt
schlachter spanisch richtige material um
richtige note
und
macht
und das ist frau weniger tue
das
und ich auch woanders her gibt es
für den umbau bezahlen mike und nicole
rund 30000 franken in costa rica braucht
es keine riesensummen um träume zu
verwirklichen
schon bald die mic seien schon mal haus
vermieten
[Musik]
die ersten touristen kommen auf kreta an
es sind die letzten ruhigen tage im
hafen von nicola
in der bar von masse buholzer laufen die
vorbereitungen auf hochtouren
bald möchte er eröffnen
[Applaus]
eröffnungsparty ist am freitag viel
glück danke
es kommt wie es kommt ich hoffe es wird
gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
muscles dekoration scheint bereits gut
anzukommen und der sap leuchtet bald
weithin sichtbar
ja das macht freude
ich möchte dich
das ist aber blick haben wir es ohne mit
roter schrift auf
das knallt durcheinander also gut
der name der bar erinnert an die
rockband rezept für die marcel als
junger mann in england gearbeitet hat
schon als 13 jähriger war es seine
lieblingsband und ihr ist er bis heute
treu geblieben
der griechische gott apollo von
lieblingsplatten label ziert nun die t
shirts von marcel und seinen
angestellten
der anderen
[Musik]
plakate aufhängen flyer verteilen marcel
will dass der sap am eröffnungsabend
voll ist
[Musik]
auf dem flughafen von heraklion wartet
ehefrau tricks auf zwei kollegen aus der
schweiz masse aber was bisher nur von
einem
die hand ihren charakter
mit jörg rechnet marcel dass auch vito
kommt ist eine überraschung
[Gelächter]
kriegs hofft dass sie nichts vom
überraschungsbesuch des zweiten gastes
an
[Musik]
heiß ist es auch auf der halbinsel neuer
weit über 30 grad sind es am ende der
trockenzeit mike nutzt die letzten regen
freien tage um die villa zu streichen
für das verbleibende stück unter dem
dach hat sich der gelernte zimmermann
eine gewagte konstruktion einfallen
lassen
[Musik]
mike improvisiert in seiner neuen heimat
gibt es keine gericht bauer und auch
beim werkzeug greift er zu einer
unorthodoxen methoden
[Musik]
für mich ist
diese gelassenheit musste er in den
vergangenen monaten erst lernen
und das ist euer zurzeit ist die
schlagkraft der familie
trifft sich der gamer schon mächtig was
sie die maggie peren
startzeit die hwk branche auch braucht
und damit sprach
krise kopf
[Musik]
tochter josefin ist heute nicht in der
schule sie sucht trost beim hund neu die
auswanderung macht ihr zu schaffen
[Musik]
david barber und marine
ja
[Musik]
doch
bleibt
[Musik]
die frage
wie bekommt man die ruhestörung und dann
gibt es zwei die sache genau
es ist nicht nur die erkältung josselin
hat heimweg sie vermisst die schweiz
denn in costa rica hat sie bis jetzt
keine freunde gefunden
[Musik]
die
marktsituation
dass die zeit die wunden heilt
[Musik]
nach einem langen tag in der bar ist
marcel wieder zu hause
rajoy
katze kasse ist immer noch nicht
aufgetaucht
jetzt schnell duschen und umziehen bevor
freund jörg kommt
damit die überraschung gelingt ist vito
schon vorher ausgestiegen und kommt in
ein paar minuten nach
[Musik]
doch nicht nur echte braucht
das war's
dann klopft es an der tür
offen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
exotische klänge auf freie krieg miriam
landolt hat für schweizer gäste ein
kulturelles programm organisiert
[Musik]
das welcome to country ist eine
traditionelle zeremonie der aborigines
soll ich übersetzen
sie sind teil von co michael komma heißt
an das land und ihre steuern high school
und
mit dem willkommen denn sie sind sie
ihre sailer
davor stellen und der däne geister da
wird sich über autoren und da damit geht
man ich halte das metrische heilige
zeremonie
das kulturprogramm hat miriam gemeinsam
mit den aborigines entwickelt
euro lag das
wir sind die einzige nation die eben
auch ihre alte kultur in sich trägt
wir haben jahrtausende alte geschichte
die bis heute lebendig sind
die elemente die landschaft die bäume
sind
wir gehen hand in hand mit ihnen
ich bin mir sicher ihr habt in eurem
land auch etwas besonderes was sind eure
bräuche
[Musik]
das ist eine besondere art zu singen zu
das vormachen
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
diesmal die kalte progression sport
classic lehrbetrieb es ganz speziell
wirklich sehr berührt und sich
eigentlich große ziel hat ein problem
sondern dass man möglichst viel geld in
lotte programms machen und das harmlose
das ist speziell sich
die bemalung stellt wichtige figuren aus
der traumzeit der mythologie der
aborigines tag
[Musik]
mit musik und tanz erzählen die
aborigines von sich und ihrer heimat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
million wünscht sich dass ihre gäste von
den abriss eines lernen
[Musik]
pferde sollen tochter jaz elle ihn
aufmuntern
die sechsjährige darf zum reitkurs
zusammen mit ihrem bruder george
wollte unbedingt kommen und jetzt hätten
sie da
die reitlehrerin kommt aus österreich
nicole hofft dass tochter josephine beim
reiten ihr heimweh vergisst und eine
freundin findet
das gemeindliche
leben
[Musik]
und
hoffen jetzt nicht weniger
[Musik]
mike ist auf dem weg zur carmelo dem
ehemaligen hausmeister
[Musik]
carmelo durfte sich auf dem grundstück
von mike und nicole eine neue bleibe
braun für sich carla und die kinder mike
hat ihnen das baumaterial bezahlt
die schweizer fühlen sich nach wie vor
für die kleine familie verantwortlich
die sie zusammen mit der bilder
übernommen haben
und sich im moment
in den situationen
und mit carlos hilfe bessert mike sein
spanisch auf
ich nehme den mal wieder mit
auf kreta geht es los
[Musik]
marcel eröffnet seine rock und blues bar
mit livemusik
[Musik]
alles ist bereit fast alles
doch ich will den verein stufe gegen
hierfür ist
dass man selber auf eigentlich kein
echter bonus
ist
aber nicht besser sei es
notwendig das war ja wohl nicht
in heft
endlich kommt der techniker mit dem
verstärker gerade noch rechtzeitig
[Musik]
wir haben lange auf dich gewartet ich
weiß
beim
an die griechische mentalität muss
marcel sich erst noch gewöhnen
[Musik]
das konzept fall der krieg mit einem
landwirtschaftsbetrieb zu erweitern wird
konkret doch auch das tagesgeschäft
läuft weiter hallo kenny ist miriam wie
geht's ich rufe an wegen deine
kreditkarte sie funktioniert nicht
könntest du das überprüfen normalerweise
mache ich das bevor die gäste abreisen
aber diesmal hatte ich es vergessen
miriam hat von ihrem gast eine andere
kreditkartennummer bekommen
einen großteil der buchungen erhält
miriam übers internet
dass ich jetzt nur noch erledigt
[Musik]
sich im bereich
bis maximal auf jetzt nur die kranken in
der hochsaison deshalb braucht aus den
lohn oder dass das ding ich nicht
gesehen und das finde ich eine note mehr
richtig
[Musik]
eine autostunde vom ferien resort
entfernt hat ehemann schön inzwischen
eine fan gefunden die zu ihrer idee
passen würde bauer will werden auf 160
hektar t räume angebaut
aufgebaut hat sie ein schweizer der
berner theo maurer durch puren zufall
ist schön in der schweiz auf den betrieb
gestoßen
eine installation republik
der welt kauft und dann plötzlich sehe
ich in gelb als gelbsucht mit dem der
staat form in new south wales oder von
new south wales zu verkaufen und so
sieht man
dass der japanische
raumfahrer
mit der farm könnte schön das konzept
umsetzen an dem nun auch investoren
interessiert sind schön will das
geschäft erweitern zusätzlich zum ferien
resort kaufte die fan stellt aboriginals
an und produziert
das gibt seiner organisches teebaumöl
das brauchste eigentlich wunderbar zum
konzept
der heim ist sozusagen und warum
wahrscheinlich dass das allheilmittel
für polizist sie das heißt jeder jedem
außerdem
ist für doris und heilwasser mit
der traditionellen medizin der
urbevölkerung hofft familie landolt ihre
geldsorgen zu lösen
produkte in kosmetikprodukte
biologisches landwirtschaftsprodukte und
zu sagen das wollen wir natürlich jetzt
prozent irgendwo zwischen vier und fünf
prozent selbst hat sehr gut 78 prozent
und kann es interessant
der investor mit dem spiel in kontakt
ist hat sich auf solche projekte
spezialisiert
nun muss der antrag der landes
schnellstmöglich bearbeitet werden
auf kreta ist die eröffnungsparty im
vollen gange rund 100 gäste sind ins
bett gekommen freunde aus der schweiz
handwerker nachbarn aber auch einige
touristen
[Musik]
als gastgeber und chef de marseille
natürlich eine rede halten auf
griechisch maklerin ende hat sie
übersetzt
dalos
deshalb
dort brauchen
quali ist
[Musik]
komm schon du weißt doch wie es geht
man ist da nämlich hatte ich werde mit
englisch beginnen
aber das zeug habe ich das lese aber
gegen wir bringen der server brüning
verstorben ist nur nicht als
sozialer mensch langsam aber das kommt
gut
freundlich
hallo zusammen ich versuche es auf
griechisch
[Applaus]
danke an jörg und vito die extra aus der
schweiz gekommen sind
[Applaus]
und nicht zuletzt vielen dank auch an
tricks meine wunderbare frau für ihr
verständnis und die geduld besonders in
den letzten sechs wochen
ich liebe dich
[Applaus]
harmonie pur zum vollkommenen glück
fehlt nun nur noch die rückkehr von kc
caché
[Musik]
fr
marcel und seine gäste haben eine lange
nacht vor sich
[Musik]
in einer stunde kommt verkäufer will auf
das ferienressort von familie landolt
kurzfristig er will endlich seine 1,9
millionen franken sehen trotz neuem
konzept und dem interessierten investor
möchte er der familie keinen aufschub
mehr geben
aber gestern natürlich klar das ist wahr
bill ist
die mädchen jetzt eigentlich not aus
bestem ruf und das macht es natürlich
druck oder
der jüngste der familie hat bereits sein
sparschwein geplündert
jetzt haben wir schon mal 200 franken
ist für beide krieg
elena woche
[Applaus]
doch bill hat keine geduld mehr er hat
den kaufvertrag gekündigt
im letzten jahr zeit läuft und hat dann
lässt man den gekloppt oder und sind
einfach wieder im blickpunkt ein
bisschen wieder da damals setzte adidas
airbus oder nicht
einfach nicht der 3 mit dem neuen
konzept sind sich schüler und miriam
sicher dass es dieses mal klappt und ihr
projekt die zusage des australischen
investors bekommt mit deiner partnerin
räte sind haben das war eine hypothek
spricht also nicht rational bekommt und
dann hast du plötzlich
ganz viele
mögliche andere gruppe
wird auch verkäufer bill an einen
positiven entscheid des investors
glauben
[Musik]
nicole gerstner wird mit neuen problemen
konfrontiert
der schwierige alltag ihrer
lateinamerikanischen nachbarn lässt sie
nicht los
sie muss carla die frau von carmelo zum
arzt bringen
karl hat schmerzen im arm
sie fahren ins nachbardorf playa kamen
dort gibt es eine der wenigen ambulanzen
in der region
wie kann ich ihnen helfen das ist eine
freundin sie hat probleme mit ihrem arm
und der schulter
ich würde mir das mal ansehen
dass wir durch den tanz marathon
gewettet dass ich heute hier sitzen dr
das haben wir haben und genau
das
machen ja
[Musik]
sie hat schwache blutgefäße wir da und
brauche in den beinen und
wahrscheinlich hier
das ist eine seltsame krankheit
das problem die ausdehnung der gefäße
könnte sie auch im gehirn haben und
das wäre dann eine sehr gefährliche
sache ein gefäß könnte platzen und
das wäre dann das ende
[Musik]
die diagnose überfordert carla sie
erleidet einen kreislaufkollaps
im moment weiß keiner ob und wie karla
wieder gesund wird
in der nächsten woche bei auf und davon
nicole und mike mission eine schwierige
entscheidung treffen wie weiter mit
carla
außerdem erwarten sie die ersten gäste
in ihrem neuen ferienbungalow
auf kreta bekommt marcel besuch von der
polizei
ich habe gerade gesehen dass es schon
fünf nach zwölf
[Musik]
daheim freut sich tricks über ein
unerwartetes wiedersehen
[Musik]
und in australien droht verkäufer bilder
familie landolt mit dem haus wurf
was passiert wenn sie das geld nicht
bekommen was ist dann am 15
und gesagt dann ziehen wir aus
[Musik]
wichtige siege mit alkohol träumen
die aus
[Musik]